- Okay, welcome Yang-Yang Zhou.
And thank you everyone for
joining online and in-person.
I'm so excited to be
introducing Yang-Yang.
She's an assistant professor
of Political Science
at the University of British Columbia,
currently at Harvard.
And she's here to
present her book project,
"Rejecting Coethnicity: The
Politics of Migrant Exclusion
"by Minoritized Citizens."
So this is part of Yang-Yang's
broader research agenda
on the causes and consequences
of migration and forced displacement
with a focus on social cohesion outcomes
and looking at how shared
ethnicity can mediate
some of the backlash effects
that we find from migration.
She also has another strand of her work
that looks specifically at
developing statistical tools
for asking sensitive
questions in sensitive context
and respecting respondent privacy.
So I'm really excited to see
some of the fruits of this labor
on both strands of research potentially.
And, yeah, join me in welcoming Yang-Yang.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks so much.
Thanks so much for having me.
I'm happy to take questions
throughout the presentation,
so please interrupt me.
All right, thank you for
that very kind introduction.
So I'm gonna start off this presentation
with a little bit of
audience participation,
so I'm gonna need you to chime in.
So we all have many
parts of our identities
that are important to us
and some of those identities
feel more important to us
compared to others at any given moment.
Here are some possible
identity categories.
They're not comprehensive.
Maybe something like
your political identity,
your race or ethnicity, your
nationality, your gender,
your job, or maybe you just
feel uniquely me at the moment,
not really feeling any
of these categories.
If I ask you to imagine you
have like 10 identity tokens
that you can distribute
across these six categories,
just asking you how would you do that
currently as you identify.
So just take a moment and think about it.
You don't have to tell me,
but just think about it.
Where would you put more
of your identity tokens
into the different categories
because you feel more
strongly about that right now.
Okay, I hope you had a moment
to think about it a little.
And now my question is
what contextual change
would shift how you just
made that distribution?
Maybe you're in a different
place geographically,
maybe other people are here,
you're in a different setting,
or the setting changes around you.
Any examples of how
this whole distribution
would shift for you
if you had a different
change in your context?
Yes, Salma.
- [Salma] Well, race or
ethnicities would be big for me.
Maybe five out of my 10
tokens would go there.
- Okay.
- But if I was
in the Middle East, it would be less,
whereas when I'm here, it's higher.
- Why is that?
- [Salma] Because here I'm a minority
so it's more salient that I'm different,
but when I'm back home, it's not salient
'cause everyone's the same as me.
- Interesting.
Yeah, so what makes you
stand out in a context?
Sometimes you feel more
identified to that.
Sarah.
- [Sarah] Sure, yeah, I mean I think I put
five of my tokens in nationality
and that was probably
because I was recent,
I'm traveling on spring break
and I just went through
these application processes,
and so that's in my mind.
- Yeah, of course, so you just
went through a whole process
that really heightened
your national identity.
Thank you so much for sharing.
I'm Chinese-American, and
so yeah, kind of the same,
like when I'm here in the
U.S. I feel very Chinese.
I think people, when they see me,
they just assume that I'm Chinese
and will try talking to me in Chinese.
But when I'm in China I feel very American
because all the Chinese
people around me are like,
"Why is your Chinese so bad?"
"Why don't you understand any
of our cultural references?"
Things like that.
And so, but if my family were here,
I don't know, I think I
would feel more Chinese.
So lots of different ways
that our context can change
and it can be very quick.
So just a small shift can really shift
how strongly we're identifying.
Right, thank you so much
for doing that little exercise with me.
So basically the big research
question I'm trying to ask
in this project is what happens
when a new group of people arrive?
How does that shift the identities
of the existing group of people there?
And specifically I'm talking
about migration and migrants.
So how do the existing
people, host citizens,
react when migrants come in,
and, in fact, they share similar cultural,
language, and ethnic backgrounds.
So those host citizens, I'm
gonna call them coethnics
because they share ethnic
ties with the new migrants.
And so if these host citizens
are not welcoming, why not?
And so a lot of the research
that's already been done
on immigration and immigrant reception
has been done in the U.S. and Europe,
and in these contexts, we know
that at least in the U.S.,
we're really looking at migration
coming from Asian countries,
from Latin America or in Europe.
It's migration coming from the Middle East
or North Africa for the most part.
And there there are a lot of religious,
racial, ethnic differences.
And so these scholars and
many others have found that
when they're looking at
white majoritized citizens,
their antipathy towards immigrants,
the new immigrants coming in,
a lot of that is driven
by fears over racial,
ethnic, religious differences.
And so from that literature,
we might assume that
absent those differences,
if there's coethnicity,
there's gonna be a lot more welcoming.
Similarly, we know from a lot
of sociological literature
that ethnic enclaves in a place,
so having host citizens
that share coethnic ties
is really important for
migrant integration.
If you're a new migrant,
you go to a country,
you try sometimes to find
people who look like you,
who share your cultural background,
they tend to be the ones who
will have networks for you.
You can find a dentist,
you can get your kids enrolled in school.
So those are really important.
And we also know from a lot
of research done in the U.S.
that if those groups are
minoritized in that country,
discrimination might foster
a sense of linked fate, of solidarity.
So all of this research
points to your coethnics
should accept you, they
should welcome you.
But of course we do see
cases of coethnic rejection
and a lot of that literature
is based on economic competition.
So maybe these new migrants
come in, they look like you,
importantly, they might share
the same set of skills as you.
And so you might feel
economically competitive,
and that's why we see coethnic rejection.
And policy makers largely
have this assumption too
that if there's coethnicity,
there's going to be welcoming.
And so this is a rather long quote
from a senior UNHCR official.
The UNHCR is the UN Agency on Refugees.
And when I talked to this person, he said,
refugees for the most
part cross the border
not too far from where they come from.
These borders, especially
in Sub-Saharan Africa,
are artificial.
I'll talk about what that
means in a little bit.
But basically you have on
both sides of the border,
populations that know each
other and from the same clan.
And the example he gives
is Dadaab camp in Kenya
with Somalis on either side,
which is the case I'm gonna talk about.
He says these communities know each other,
they're homogenous,
In this kind of context,
migrants don't go where
they're not welcomed or wanted.
And so you move to parts of the region
where you know people will not reject you.
And this is important because
the context he's talking about
is people who are migrating
because they're experiencing
some form of displacement
either through conflict
or natural disaster.
And we know that these people,
the number of these people
are growing every year around the world,
but they're mostly staying
in Global South context.
So they're not really
going to U.S. or Europe.
They're mostly, as that
UNHCR official said,
"They're just crossing the border."
Here's another way to look at this data.
My co-author Andrew Shaver and
I collected geo-located data
on where these displacement
populations are,
like refugee camps, asylum
seeker, communities, IIDP camps.
And again you can see most of them are,
a lot of them are in Sub-Saharan Africa
and other parts of the Global South.
And so taking in that context,
my theory is that when the
host state and politicians
stigmatize migrants in a place,
those host citizens, the co-ethnics,
who share ties with those migrants,
they're gonna feel this fear
of being mistaken for
this stigmatized group.
They're going to fear being migrantized
and discriminated against by the state
and by other majoritized
pop host citizens.
So they're co-nationals
who belong to majority ethnic groups.
They're gonna heighten
their national identity
in order to distance themselves
because that's something
that they don't share
with the new migrant groups.
And they may espouse
anti-migrant sentiments,
and support anti-migrant policies,
which is particularly
troubling because, again,
when the migrants come in,
they're looking towards these
communities to welcome them.
And so very quickly, this is sort of like
how I lay out my cases.
Here we can see these
two states of the world
either the host government
is stigmatizing migrants or they're not.
When they do and you have coethnic groups
who are located kind of proximate to them,
in this case geographically.
That's going to follow the case
where they're going to
reject those migrants
because they're gonna fear
being mistaken for migrant themselves.
When they're farther away,
maybe they feel less of that pressure
and so they might react more neutrally.
And then for your noncoethnic,
your majoritized groups,
they usually just take in
or help perpetuate some of
these negative stereotypes,
so they're gonna act exclusionary.
Whereas in the case where the state
does not stigmatize migrants,
even if you are mistaken
for being a migrant,
you're not going to really feel
like you're suffering
any negative consequences
for the most part,
and so here is where
we will see solidarity.
These are the cases where,
yeah, coethnics, are welcoming.
Okay, so I'm going to test this theory
mostly in the East African context,
but at the end I'll talk
about some other contexts
where I think this phenomenon happens,
which is a lot of places in the world.
And the three countries I'm gonna focus on
are Tanzania, Kenya, and Uganda.
Here's a map of all East Africa,
you can see that these three countries,
they host a lot of refugees
and from neighboring countries,
so a lot of groups are shared.
So they all host like
South Sudanese for example.
And they've been hosting
refugees for a very long time.
In fact, when the UNHCR starts recording,
how many numbers of refugees
are in these countries,
they basically start at
the year of independence.
So even at the year of independence,
there are refugees there,
meaning that there have
been refugees there
before independence and they
only start recording it then.
And, yeah, the refugees
that they are hosting across the border,
they all tend to be
crossing colonial borders.
And that means a lot of these borders
when you hear artificial colonial borders,
it's because colonial authorities
in the late 1800s, early 1900s,
in Western Europe drew these lines.
So they're not drawn by
indigenous groups living there.
And so what that mostly means today is
you can cross some of these borders
and you won't see anything,
you won't see the line.
And communities across these borders
kind of just live as one
especially if they're coethnic.
And so this is how the
cases in East Africa
sort of fit my theory.
I'm gonna go through them line by line,
but let's start with the
Ha Tanzanians in Kigoma.
And so this is a case where the Tanzanians
in the host country of Tanzania,
they are coethnic with
the Burundian refugees
coming in from the other
side of the border,
but they're living in a context
where the host government
stigmatizes refugees.
And so Tanzania has been hosting
again refugees since independence,
but for throughout the 2000s,
I think they were hosting
about like not too many,
maybe around 50,000 Congolese refugees
who've been there since the
90s, and that was pretty stable.
And around that time up until 2014,
there was only one
refugee camp in Tanzania,
it's called Nyarugusu.
And here's what it looked like in 2014
when you're there on the ground,
they looked like
semi-permanent structures.
They have their own blocks, their schools,
and, yeah, it's mostly Congolese refugees.
In early 2015 there was a political crisis
in the neighboring country of Burundi.
The president there wanted
to change the constitution
and run for a third term that
kicked off a lot of protests.
And so a lot of people
especially thinking about
the genocide there that just happened
like a few years earlier,
they went to Tanzania,
and here you can see that the refugee camp
basically in a few months'
time, more than doubled in size.
And I think it was about
like 230,000 refugees
from Burundi came.
And so this area is hosting
like 50,000, here it's like 230.
And so what that looks like here,
it's not so many permanent structure,
it's just rows and rows of UNHCR tents.
And this is a context where
the host government of Tanzania
represses the Burundian refugees.
So they force them to be in camps.
They're not allowed to leave the camps.
Recently they have been pressuring them
to return to Burundi.
They've been forcibly
disappearing and torturing them.
And then the rhetoric
around Burundian refugees
is one of criminality, security concerns,
disease concerns, overcrowding.
And so to give you a sense,
here is the country of Tanzania.
These are where the sort of economic
and political capitals are in the country,
and the region that we're
interested in is Kigoma.
It's all the way over here.
It's a border region,
bordering Burundi right there.
As a border region, it is poorer
compared to many of the
other regions in Tanzania.
Kigoma often ranks worse
in terms of like school
outcomes, health outcomes,
so it is a marginalized area.
In Kigoma, the majority
group in that region
is called the Ha,
but they are a minority group nationally.
And, yeah, they are considered coethnic
with the Burundi who
choose on the other side,
meaning they do speak the same language,
they have similar cultural backgrounds,
they often intermarry,
and that sort of border in between the two
is kind of nonexistent.
So even when I was there,
it was really easy just
to walk across the border.
And communities on either side
use the same water sources,
go to the same markets.
And so this is zooming in
on that area of Kigoma.
Here is the sort of
regional capital Kigoma town
and these are the three refugees
camp that are there now.
So Nyarugusu was the one that
I showed you photos before.
That was there sort of, yeah,
to receive all the new refugees in 2015.
At the end of 2016,
there were so many new refugees coming in
that they opened up these two other camps,
Nduta and Mtendeli.
And so in 2015 just a few months
after the refugees started coming in,
I was there and I got to do
some community focus groups,
and so here I chose these sort
of 10 community focus groups.
I did, that sort of blue
dot is where Nyarugusu is,
and then these are like the
10 different communities
that I kind of randomly selected
to do community focus groups.
Each focus group I think had
around like 10 to 15 people.
And again these are all Tanzanians.
They're Ha Tanzanians.
And then the following summer
I came back and I ran a survey.
So this shows you basically
where my survey respondents are.
To give you a sense
there's like a lot of
geographic variation, right?
Some of the survey respondents
are quite close to the camp
and some are far.
And again in the survey,
this is how I sort of measure identity.
It's that same distributional measure
that I showed you before except
the categories are Kigoma,
that's like their subnational
regional identity,
your ethnic group, your
national identification,
your region of East Africa,
maybe you feel pan-African,
or you have this like sort of
catchall kind of last category
of I'm just me, I don't really
fit any of these things.
And so in my survey I
basically gave them 10 tokens
to distribute across these
six categories, yeah?
- [Audience Member] Just two
quick clarifying questions.
So I'm wondering what your use of the word
ethnicity and coethnic.
- Yeah.
- So the example you gave like
Ha Tanzanians with Tutsi Burundians.
So they're not the same ethnicity,
but they're considered coethnic.
So.
- Yeah, with the Hutu, yeah.
Yeah, I should have defined coethnicity.
That's a great question.
So coethnicity in my
case is sort of it's both
that you yourself have some sort of
recognition of coethnicity.
So based on like descent-based ties
or a myth of a common
origin, all of those things.
So you have some agency over that.
And so those communities in Burundi,
I think they're called Hutu,
but in Tanzania they're called Ha,
but they do, they speak the
same language, they intermarry,
and so there there's like
the self-recognition part,
but I think the other
really interesting part
of defining coethnicity
is like your recognition
that other people will group
you into the same group.
And so there's a part of that
where you don't have much control over,
but as like a second order concern,
you recognize that other people
are going to say that we're coethnic
even if I might not
consider myself coethnic.
So I mean like with other East Asians,
like people coming from Japan or Korea,
like I might not say that we're coethnic,
but I recognize that other
Americans would look at us
and say, oh yeah, you are a
part of the same ethnic group.
- [Audience Member] So is it based
on like physical descriptors?
- It could be language, yeah.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
- Cultural markings, dress,
all the sort of things that we might,
trying to find ethnicity with.
But I think it's just the
important part is like
part of it is my own self-recognition
and part of it is my
recognition of how others,
outsiders might group me.
- [Audience Member] And
why is religion not one
of the circles?
- Oh that's a great question.
Okay, if I put religion in here,
the whole region is very Christian,
and it's the same across the border.
So if I had put in your religion,
I think everyone would
really just put that.
And so the categories
I'm really interested in
are obviously ethnic group
and your national identity.
So comparing ethnic and national.
So I wanted to make sure
that the other categories
were kind of just not many
people would use those categories
so I could see this variation.
But, yeah, if I put in religion,
I think everyone would just
put all their tokens into religion.
But it is a very important identity.
Okay, so the other part of the survey,
so that's how I measure
identity in the survey,
the other part was half
of the respondents,
and I should say there was about
like 2000 respondents here,
half of them just started the survey
without knowing it's a
survey about refugees.
They got those questions about identity,
they saw that measure.
So they're going in with the survey
not knowing it's about refugees.
The other half start off with
questions about refugees.
So a little bit of information
like there's this many that just came in
in the last few months,
they live in Nyarugusu.
We show them a map of where Nyarugusu is
and then ask them some questions
like do you know which
countries they're from?
And some other factual questions.
So for them they're really primed
to be thinking about refugees
'cause they just answered
a whole bunch of questions about them.
So that group I'm gonna
call the treatment group
'cause they're primed to
be thinking about refugees.
So in the control group,
again these people don't know
it's a survey about refugees.
This is what those identities,
their ethnic identification
and their national
identification look like,
the difference between coethnics,
the HA versus non coethnics.
Now I will note that in this area,
there's very few non-coethnics.
I think my coethnics are
like 90% of the sample.
So there's just not that much
variation for non-coethnics.
But even still you can
see that for coethnic,
compared to non-coethnics,
they feel more ethnic.
And that probably makes sense
because they are the ethnic
majority in the region.
But if we turn to the treatment effect,
so what is it for people
who actually answer
all those questions about refugees first?
We see there's no difference
now on ethnic identity,
but for your coethnics,
they feel more national.
And so so far it looks,
it's suggested that it's fitting my theory
that when people, when
coethnics are feeling like,
in this case, sort of
psychologically proximate to refugees
because they're being reminded of them,
they're being reminded
that, hey, here's this group
that kind of shares our ethnic identity,
they end up feeling more national
because that's the thing
that differentiates them.
We can look at this another way.
So here on the x-axis,
we're looking at distance from the camp,
because, again, when we surveyed people,
I chose some people to be
quite far from the camp,
some people to be quite close.
And so here this means you're
really close to the camp,
here you're much farther away.
And we can see this is just at baseline.
Again this is the control group
who don't even know that
this is a question about,
this is a survey about refugees.
For the people who are super close,
they also feel more national.
And so this is just like
an observational component.
Just by being close to the camp,
they're gonna feel more national.
Yeah?
- [Audience Member] Just
to clarify a question
on the baseline,
do you also see that for
your larger treatment group,
those who are closer to the camp,
do they answer those
questions about refugees
more accurately in terms of like
knowing that their ethnicity
and like knowing where--
- Yeah, that's a great question.
So for the control group,
they get those same questions,
they just get it at the end of the survey.
So I do get measures for both
and there's no difference.
I think maybe, no, wait,
there is a little bit of a difference.
The people who are closer
know that there's definitely
Burundian refugees there.
I think everyone knows that
there's Burundian refugees.
Maybe the people who are farthest away,
I think there's some
percentile I looked at.
They would also say there's
Rwanda's refugees there,
and there aren't.
So I think maybe they do
have less information,
but everyone knows that there's
Burundian refugees there.
That's a great question.
And here I'm gonna show you that marginal,
that additional effect
of getting the survey
treatment by distance.
And you can see that for people
who are closest to the camp,
when you get that reminder
that the survey is about refugees,
they also feel more national,
and that effect sort of dissipates
as you get farther and farther away.
- [Audience Member] In terms
of the social networks,
like are there social
networks that connect
the two sides together?
Like I'm thinking about Syrian refugees
that come to the U.S.,
like they very quickly
tap into like the area--
- Yes.
- of the Muslim
communities here and they help them
with resources and whatever.
So is there like any network happening?
Or are they just like,
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] Oh, we're not them.
They're a whole different--
- That is a great question.
So the next part of this,
I'm gonna talk about focus groups,
but before I get into
focus groups' results,
the focus groups themselves
I think shed a lot of light into this.
One focus group I went
to was at the border.
I sort of start off my book
introduction with the story.
When I went I sort of went
to ask these questions
like what do you think about the people
on this other side of the border?
What do you think about refugees?
Tell me what it means to be Tanzanian.
Those were the kinds of questions I asked.
And there was like a
village elder there and he,
the whole sort of focus group,
the other community members
started turning on him,
and they were saying,
"Oh that's our village elder"
"and he hides refugees in his house."
"Like they're there right now if you go,"
"like they're supposed to be in the camp,"
"but he's hiding them.""
And they said that like
there were sex workers
and he was involved in
like criminal activity.
And we basically had to kinda
change the topic a little
'cause it was getting really heated.
And at the end, I approached
him, and I was like,
"I'm very sorry, like do you
wanna tell me anything or?"
And he said that he was hosting
his niece who is Burundian
on the other side of the border,
and he's like, yeah, they're my family,
yeah, they're staying with me.
But it actually ended
up causing a lot of like
mistrust throughout the community,
and a lot of the community
members are trying to like,
yeah, go to immigration
officials to tell on him
so that a bus can come
and take those Burundians,
his family members, to the camp,
because they're supposed
to be in the camp.
Yeah, so, and there was a lot of rumors
about people hiding
refugees in their houses,
because, in a lot of cases,
they're not just like coethnics,
but they're kin, they're
literal relatives.
- [Audience Member] And
what is the composition
of both the control and
the treatment group?
I mean do you have like a good mixture of,
I don't know, gender and age
and other
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member]
Socioeconomic environment.
- So for the treatment
groups, it's randomized.
So it is, because I have
like 2,000 respondents,
it is very balanced on
all of those things.
And just in my sample as a whole,
I have practically half men and women.
But the thing that is imbalanced though
is of course like distance to the camp.
So people who are closer have
different characteristics
than people who are farther away.
- [Audience Member] And
the results that you get,
that you have shown so far,
do they still hold depending
on these other characteristics?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
So one way we can do that is
just covariate adjustment.
Try and control for all the other
demographic characteristics
that we measure for.
But another way I try to get at that is,
if you recall in the map
that I showed you a few slides earlier,
there's actually two other camps
that at this point of the
survey they don't exist yet,
but a few, like almost a year later,
there's going to be two future camps,
and so I basically use them
as like a placebo test, yeah.
And so I can look at this exact thing
but it's at a distance to Nduta
or distance to Mtendeli camp,
and there's no results there.
And so we can think those future camps
kind of share the same characteristics
of like what makes it that refugees,
that there's a camp there.
Good question.
Okay, so that was just
giving you an overview
of how in this context, coethnics,
especially when they're
reminded that refugees are there
or that they're physically
close to refugees,
they feel more national.
But what does the sort of
national identity mean?
We know national identity
encompasses a lot of
different attitudes, feelings,
and so we can turn to sort
of the focus group evidence
to look at this a bit more qualitatively.
I only did 10 focus groups.
So just keep that in mind.
It's a pretty small end.
But I sort of had the same approach
where I wanted to do
something experimental.
So on half of the groups,
randomly we would kinda do the same thing.
We'd start off the
discussion with refugees,
and then we end the
discussion with what is it,
what is your national
identity mean to you?
What does it mean to be Tanzanian?
And so those are five groups
and, again, each group has
a mixture of men and women.
And then in the no prime condition,
that's the control condition,
we just flipped it.
So we talk about national
identity, living in the border,
sort of the issues with your community,
what does it mean to be Tanzanian first,
and then we talk about refugees, right?
And so here's a quote from
the no prime condition
when sort of living in
the border comes up,
this person says, "We have villages
"on either side of the border
that use the same river.
"Of course we know each other.
"You will find a Burundian
with uncles in Tanzania."
So this is very much a story
of coethnicity and kinship.
- [Audience Member] So
you have five focus groups
in the prime condition
and five in the non-prime.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
- And then in the prime condition,
when we talk about refugees first,
these are kind of the quotes that I see.
So here look, it's like,
"We know each other."
Here it's "Refugees will
try to hide in our villages.
"But we Tanzanians know each other.
"It's clear we're not refugees."
So here the conversation was
probably like how do you tell.
This is like a question
that I try to ask everyone,
like is it easy to tell
who's Burundian or not?
Because like appearance, language,
all of these things are very similar.
This other person says,
"The new refugees are not good people
"because of their nature."
So they're already sort
of dehumanizing them.
"To kill a person, they see it as normal."
So a lot of quotes that are distancing.
And so we can gather all of
these focus group sentiments.
I think there's comments,
around like 300 comments,
and I had an RA basically code them
based on when they're talking
about national identity,
are they using in-group
terms or out-group terms?
Are they talking about
their national identity
as something that's
inherited or is it inclusive?
Do they want citizenship
to be restricted or open?
And in all of these you can
see the treatment group,
when we talk about refugees first,
there's a lot more
exclusionary nationalism
and restrictions on citizenship.
Okay, so that gives, I just picked out
sort of some bits of evidence
from the Tanzania case.
Moving on to Kenya very quickly,
I'm just gonna show you
one result from Kenya.
And the Kenya example is kind of similar.
They are in a context
where the Kenyan state
does stigmatize migrants, refugees,
but really they mostly target one group
which are the Somali refugees.
And so there are Somali Kenyans
that live near the main
Somali refugee camp Dadaab.
And in this case, in the
previous case in Tanzania,
I don't have that many non-coethnics,
but in here I could do a survey
in another part of the country
where there are other
refugees, the South Sudanese,
and in that case, the people,
the host community living there,
they're not considered coethnic.
So they have different traditions,
they tell me that they look differently,
they dress differently.
They actually say like,
"Oh, like the refugees
are much taller than us.
"So when we see someone from far away,
"we just know that, like just by looking,
"we can tell that they're a refugee."
And in Kenya similarly, every
few years the Kenyan state
sort of threatens to
shut down all the camps
and force people back to their countries.
And here, there's different reports.
There's a couple done
by Human Rights Watch
that say the Kenyan police,
they will go after refugees
who fall under curfews,
and especially in times where
there's like terrorist attacks
that have happened in the past years.
There's a lot of
restrictions around refugees,
Somali refugees, whether
they can leave the camps.
And when they encounter Somali Kenyans,
so these are Kenyan citizens
of Somali ethnic descent,
they will paint them with the same brush.
They will also arrest them,
put them under curfew,
and here's a police, quoting, saying,
"You're all terrorists.
"Like you're all the
same to me basically."
And so this past fall,
I did a very similar
kinda survey experiment
in these two parts of Kenya.
Dadaab, this is bordering Somalia,
and so Dadaab hosts Somalia refugees.
Kakuma camp hosts South Sudanese
refugees for the most part.
They're also in sort of border regions.
So when we go, this is Kakuma camp,
it's like technically two camps,
and these are my survey respondents there.
They're mostly of Turkana ethnicity,
so I'm gonna call them Turkana Kenyans.
And again they're not really considered
coethnic with the refugees near them.
This shows the three camps under Dadaab.
And in the purple are my
Somali Kenyan respondents
and they are coethnic.
And so just one quick result,
again when I use that sort of
distributional identity measure,
we can compare, this is just at baseline,
ethnic identification
and national identification.
Here we can see for both groups,
the Garissa is Somali Kenyans coethnic,
these are non-coethnic, and
both are pretty similar.
They feel pretty ethnic,
somewhat national but less so.
But under the survey, I had
two treatment conditions,
one I'm gonna call camp closure,
and this is sort of, I presented
it as a radio news story,
where they heard a little radio snippet
about the Kenyan government is announcing
that in the past wanted
to close all the camps
for different reasons.
One is like security concerns,
environmental concerns.
And so again, it's sort of is a,
hopefully like a nuanced
and not super heavy-handed,
but it is a reminder
that refugees are
stigmatized in the country.
The other treatment is
called refugee rights.
So Kenya is sort of like a
transitional stage right now
because last year they
passed new legislation
that would actually treat
refugees more inclusively.
It's not being implemented
yet, but it is possible.
So some things like allowing
refugees to leave the camps,
allowing them the formal right to work.
So this treatment, they
heard a news story that was,
yeah, basically saying, hey,
refugees might be treated
better in this country,
they might be given new rights.
And then the baseline
was like a placebo story
about motorcycle taxis.
And what we can see is that
under the sort of stigmatizing
news story camp closure,
for coethnics, again they feel less ethnic
and they feel more national.
Under the treatment where they're hearing
that refugees might be given more rights,
they actually,
these effects are not
statistically significant,
but for the top one,
you can see they actually
feel a little bit more ethnic.
And again that's the identity
that they share with the refugees.
For your non-coethnics,
just null results basically.
And that's what we would expect.
Their identification does
not hinge on how refugees
near them are being
treated for the most part,
'cause they know they're never gonna be
mistaken as a refugee.
And so in this same survey I
wanted to ask more explicitly,
do you ever get
misidentified as a refugee?
Does your family ever get misidentified?
If so, how upset would you feel?
And if you've been misidentified,
who misidentified you?
And so you can select from
different groups of people.
And of course Somali Kenyans
were way more likely to say
that they have been misidentified.
I think one out of four
of my survey respondents
said that they were misidentified.
And for them, so for the 25%
that say they've been misidentified,
when I ask who, it's
overwhelmingly the police
and it's overwhelmingly
other government officials.
So it's the state who misidentifies them.
And when that happens,
it's really consequential,
because that means they're
gonna be put under curfew,
they might be jailed, detained,
asked to see their
papers, things like that.
All right, so lastly this
is the final case of Uganda
where it's kind of like my control case
in which there is coethnicity,
but they're living in a context
where the Ugandan state does not,
although it's authoritarian,
it does not stigmatize the refugees there.
In fact, politicians often talk
and newspapers talk about refugees
as if they are brothers and sisters.
And so in this case I
would expect solidarity.
And so here's some examples.
A lot of newspaper examples saying
like "Uganda stands out
in refugee hospitality.
"They're a model of how to treat refugees.
"Refugees are like our brothers."
That's often the sort of
elite rhetoric that we see.
Of course this doesn't mean
there isn't any social conflict
between host communities
and the refugees there,
but I think there's just a lot less
of what we should see
in those other cases.
And so this fall, I have some funding.
I'm gonna do a very similar
survey in this part of Uganda.
It's like the sort of northwestern part.
This is one of the largest
refugee camps in the world.
It's called Bidi Bidi and
it hosts South Sudanese.
And the host communities around there
I'm expecting are going to be coethnic.
You can already see here, so
this is Kampala, the capital,
and sort of where all the refugees are.
You can already see here that
in Tanzania it was like three camps,
in Kenya it's two camps, here
there's over 30 settlements.
And that's because refugees
are allowed to live
where they want to for the most part.
They're not forced to be in camps.
So here they just sort of naturally settle
all along the western part of the country.
All right, so in conclusion,
I think in this project I
really wanna emphasize that
hosting policies, political rhetoric,
institution structures
can shape the relationship
between citizens and migrants.
A lot of the immigration literature we see
asks about public opinion
of how citizens feel towards immigrants
and it almost assumes that
the context is a given.
So do you oppose migrants
because you feel economically competitive
or racial discrimination?
But what I'm saying is that
there's structures in place
that can really shape those things.
Second, when we do see instances
of anti-migrant policies and rhetoric,
they're almost in a way doubly pernicious.
They're pernicious first
because they teach majoritized citizens
who may not know anything about migrants.
They give them stereotypes
and negative things to repeat.
But they're doubly pernicious
because for the community
that does know these people,
they're coethnics, sometimes
literally they're relatives,
they make them feel like
they have to strategically reject them.
And again those are the people
that we might expect to be most welcoming,
but in this case they feel
pressured to reject them.
So that's why I say
it's doubly pernicious.
Next, public backlash to migrant shocks.
A lot of this backlash we've been seeing
in Western countries is
not inevitable however.
If we can learn something
from Uganda, it could be that,
host governments have agencies again
to shape that relationship
and they can do various things
to make it so that there's
less social conflict.
Also I think in this project,
something that seems obvious,
but we should consider
is things like ethnicity,
they're not just variables
to put on the right-hand side
of the regression, right?
They are, in my case,
both an independent and
a dependent variable.
We can feel more ethnic, less ethnic.
We can try and change
our ethnic identities
in different ways.
And lastly, the book is going to end
considering on some other
cases where this might happen.
So for generalizability,
I'm collecting data,
focus group surveys right now
on the case of Venezuelan
migrants in Colombia,
again where we see a lot of coethnicity,
Afghan refugees in Pakistan,
especially Afghan refugees
of Pashtun descent,
Pashtun minoritized groups in Pakistan,
and with Asian-Americans in the U.S.
So I'm actually gonna do that
focus group in a few weeks
and I'm very scared but excited.
Okay great, thank you so much.
Thanks for your questions.
(audience applauding)
- [Audience Member] So I'm thinking
about Hakeem Jefferson at
Stanford has this paper
about the politics of respectability.
It looks like you're familiar with it.
But what he's trying to explain
is why African-Americans
have a high rate of supporting
like pretty like tough on crime policies,
which seems like it doesn't make sense
because it disproportionately
affects their own group.
And the idea is that they want
to separate themselves from like,
good African-Americans
wanna separate themselves
from the bad kind.
- Right.
- And they wanna like signal,
they want some way for people
to actually discriminate
bad and good ones.
- Right?
- [Audience Member] And I think
there's like similar research looking
at immigrants in the U.S.
having anti-immigrant attitudes
and it's again
- Right.
- [Audience Member] Trying to be like
we're not like those kind.
- Exactly, yeah.
- Of immigrants.
So do you think this is
kind of another instance
of that same phenomena
of like trying to differentiate yourself
to avoid discrimination
and trying to like signal
that you are different?
Is it kind of the same?
- Yeah, I think so.
I know I probably would feel the pressure
to say, no, it's completely different.
But, no, I think it is very similar.
It's all built on social identity theory.
Yeah, Hakeem and I chatted a
few weeks ago and we're like,
yeah, we can kinda see
this phenomenon everywhere
of if there's a group that's
going to make me look bad,
make my family look bad,
if I might be lumped in with that group,
then what can I do to separate us?
And I think what he and
I were talking about
was that's also context-specific, right?
So the survey on respectability,
it kind of depends on who they think
that they're maybe
answering this question to
or who they think that
they're signaling to.
I think in that case they're signaling
to other Americans, white Americans,
but if they were put
in a different context,
they might not act that way, right?
So I think this is the same.
And I can just show in one survey, right?
Like just shifting how the
survey questions are worded
is gonna shift how people react.
- [Audience Member] And
just a related point,
does it need to be state
stigmatization of the minority
as opposed to just general stigmatization?
Like how do?
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] View
public, just public opinion
versus the state's actions,
'cause they're not always aligned.
- That is how I'm kind of
struggling with this book.
So thank you for picking out the part
that I think is tough because in my story,
it's very much like a top-down,
like public opinion
follows elite rhetoric.
It's kind of like that's
all the rest kind of world.
And I think it's justifiable in the cases.
Tanzania and Uganda are authoritarian,
Kenya is more democratic,
but still I would say
especially on an issue
that the state really cares about,
but if refugees are just in the camps,
it's not like the public already
has xenophobic attitudes,
I think without state rhetoric.
I think in that case it's justified
that it's sort of top down,
public opinion follows elite rhetoric.
But that's not true everywhere.
And so for example,
Sandra Rosa's doing some
really cool work in Colombia,
I think you're on, are you
on some of those projects?
- [Audience Member] We
were during the pandemic.
- Oh gosh, (Yang-Yang laughs) okay.
Yeah, but she's finding that in that case
what's really interesting
is the Colombian state
has all these like very generous policies
towards Venezuelans,
helping them regularize,
letting them stay there
and work for like 10 years,
giving them access to services.
And yet public opinion has really
had a backlash towards those policies.
And so Colombian citizens
have actually been
really negative about
it, and that seems weird.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, I think.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] What happens as well
is some of the local politicians--
- Right.
- I was gonna say,
because in general,
I mean the Venezuelan
refugees in Colombia,
they have been accepted,
they don't live in camps,
they have been given the right to work
especially during the pandemic
'cause they were also
given access to health.
But the question, I mean the
comment there is more like,
I mean some xenophobic and more populist--
- Right.
- [Audience Member] Comments
from some of the politician.
I think that's what
sparked as well.
- Like left-wing politicians.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] That
sparks the negative sentiment.
And if they just said that,
I mean the criminals are the Venezuelans
and this is what happened
and then they amplify whatever
incident that has happened
that then generalized to the other part
that these are all the Venezuelan.
That's what probably you
managed to shift the opinion,
because originally actually
the government of Colombia
was not gonna give them access to health
and therefore the vaccines,
but there was actually a
backlash from the people.
The Colombians say it should be
and then they switched that, so.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] So maybe
you might want to nuances
with some of the locals
and then maybe politicians
and then nuance them in their rhetoric
of just general populism that they have.
- That's great, thank you.
I mean, I will say what we've,
so I've done some surveys
with Maggie Peters and
Alicia Holland on Colombians.
Specifically we did a survey
where we target Cucuta and Cali.
Cucuta's the border city,
and so we think, we thought going in like,
because there's a lot of history
of like circular migration,
just migrating for work every
day, that sort of thing,
that the expectation is that
they would be more
welcoming of Venezuelans,
versus in Cali there's not as many there
and so they might not know,
they might not feel the connection,
and they would be more
anti-Venezuelan migrants
and anti these policies.
But we actually found the opposite.
In Cucuta, people were more likely to say
that Venezuelans will
not integrate well here,
that there's a big cultural difference
between Colombians and Venezuelans,
and like a whole bunch of other things.
So that sort of surprised us.
But I was also like, oh,
well, maybe that sort of fits in here
that other Colombians
when they think of Cucuta,
they also think, well, they're basically,
they could be Venezuelan.
Like there's so much
cross-border migration.
So maybe they face sort of
similar identity pressures.
Yeah.
- [Man] Yeah, I happen
to be an active volunteer
in a refugee resettlement
group in New Haven.
That's a Jewish ethnic group
that's settling many
Muslim ethnic group peoples
from Syria and Afghanistan.
And the observation that I
have related to controversy
is the fact that after the
refugees get comfortable
by being settled by a Jewish American,
and they see nice things happening,
they finally say, "Oh my God,
"I didn't know what to
expect to be resettled
"or helped by a Jewish-American.
"I thought it was gonna be terrible
"because that's what I knew before."
And vice versa could have happened
that the Jewish volunteers
could have said,
"Well, with all the
propaganda we hear about
"the Middle East and Israel,
"that it would have gone the other way."
So that in fact your preexisting
conditions are really there
and it invalidates
everything you're saying.
- Yeah, thank you so much
for that observation.
Yeah, I mean basically, I
think what you're looking at
is two groups that might not necessarily
know about each other that much before,
but through the sort of positive contact,
they're learning to change misperceptions
that they might have
held against each other.
And I think it's interesting that
put into a different context.
like here in New Haven,
that contextual change can also change
how they think about their own identities
and other people's identities.
If you wanna learn more
about contact theory work,
I would redirect you to
Salma Mousa's research.
- [Audience Member] Do you
want to ask your question?
- [Participant] Sure, yeah,
so I think the first one
is about the role of kinship
and how that might kind of,
how that might complicate
some of these dynamics
and whether that's something
that you see across your cases
and it's something that
you're able to pick up on
in the surveys as well.
And then I'll ask
my gender question.
- Yeah.
- [Participant] So I think in your theory,
the way I understand it,
some of it has to do,
the role of the state
to me feels important
because it kind of sets up high stakes
for being misidentified, right?
And I'm thinking how those stakes
might vary for men and women
particularly when refugees
are seen as a security threat.
And I'm particularly
thinking of the Pakistan case
where it is Pashtun males who
are being kind of targeted
for kind of police abuse
and also racial profiling,
right?
- Right.
- [Participant] And so I'm wondering
if you see that dynamic in your cases
and what you would expect based on that.
- Yeah, I think so.
And I can only say we basically
only started this research.
So this is based on like
a handful of focus groups
that we've done in Pakistan.
And by we, I'm collaborating on this work
with Niloufer Siddiqi at SUNY Albany
and Michelle Malek at Harvard.
And so in those focus groups,
we basically did a couple focus
groups with Afghan refugees
and a couple focus groups with
Pashtun community Pakistanis.
And we did divide it up by gender.
And what was really interesting
was when we talked to the, not we,
but the research firm talked to the women
and asked about Afghan refugees,
in the beginning of the focus groups,
it was all really, really positive.
Like, yeah, there's a lot of connections,
shared connections.
But as the focus group went on,
a lot more negative things came out.
Things like economic competition.
Yeah, and they did mention like
men would get misidentified.
There'd be problems with their businesses.
But for the women, it was pretty
positive in the beginning.
In the male focus groups,
it was kind of negative
from the very beginning.
So that's sort of one thing
that we saw that was different.
It could be for other factors,
but that is something that we observed.
We are planning to do a larger survey
on this, on coethnicity.
And what we're thinking right
now for the survey design
is to randomize the enumerator,
so whether the enumerator
is Pashtun or not.
So basically does it
matter if you're answering
these types of questions
to like an outsider
or to someone who you think is an insider?
And then the other thing is
we wanna vary the regions
where Pashtun is the
sort of regional majority
versus whether they're also
in the regional minority.
And so maybe there's sort of these
demographic considerations there.
- [Audience Member] Kind
of on this, I was thinking,
I was wondering if you
can get any variation
on how easy it is to mistake someone
for a member of the refugee group
or whether you can get some leverage,
like just based on some
physical attributes.
So I think gender is a great idea.
This is a really good way
'cause the observable
implication from your theory
is that you're gonna get,
those people are the ones
who are gonna distance
themselves the most,
the ones who are the most easily mistaken
for the stigmatized group.
So I feel like gender
is one way to get at it.
I mean, Somalis in Kenya is another way,
because like Somalis have a very different
physical features from other Kenyans.
I wonder if there's like
some other way to get at this
based on language, based on like religion,
maybe how they dress.
Like do you have some--
- [Participant] Accents?
- [Audience Member] Yeah, accents,
like some variation of how easy it is--
- How do you think would be a
creative way to measure that?
Like say we're doing our survey
- Yeah.
- In Pakistan, like,
I mean, so we're gonna try and like,
the thing that we wanna randomize
is the enumerator identity.
And I think a question we can ask
at the beginning of the survey
is like asking the enumerator to guess.
So I asked our enumerators
in Kenya to guess as well.
Our enumerators in Kenya
were all from those areas
because they had to
know the local languages
and they guessed 100%.
Like they knew exactly.
Like they looked at the person,
they were like, oh, this person's Turkana,
this person's Somali, this
person is some other group.
It was like 99.9% correct.
But I wonder if, yeah, if we vary
the identity of the enumerator
and ask them at the beginning,
like before you even start the interview,
check off who you think this person is
just based on looking at them.
- [Audience Member] I was
thinking just in terms
of analyzing the survey
data you already have.
- Oh, yeah.
- Like whether
that's something that mediates the,
it's not just coethnicity,
but you can actually get
more nuanced measures.
So like if there are men
for example and coethnics,
like whether that treatment
applies to something?
- Yeah, that's possible.
I don't think I,
I haven't really looked at
the intersectionality of this,
but, yeah, that's great.
- [Audience Member] I
was thinking about it
from like the perspective
of how easy it is to be mistaken,
but like also what are the consequences
of being mistaken, right?
So if you're a man like being
mistaken by a police officer,
if you're then perceived
as a security threat--
- Right.
- [Audience Member] Is likely
a lot more consequential
than if you're mistaken as a woman
and not perceived as a security threat
because of gendered
- I see.
- expectations.
- Yeah.
I think in Kenya,
they do perceive women also as security
risk.
- Interesting, yeah.
- Yeah.
But I mean I'll look at that.
That's super interesting, thank you.
I think at some point
for this book project,
I need to stop collecting new data.
I'm not sure how to do that yet.
(Yang-Yang laughs)
- [Salma] Any other questions
from the people on Zoom?
- Thanks so much.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- Thanks, this is super fun.
(audience applauding)